DETROIT AND THE MIDWEST BUILDINS
THY S AN
SPETLEASOME,E NEXT
>> MR.SIDENT-ELECTVIU H FOR ENT
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I  HUMBLEDURGEYTHINGN
POWER TONSE THS
ON
MY HOMETOWN SOBREND WAS BUILT
BY THE POWF AMAN TATION. ALONG
ITSELF
COUNTRVELIHOODS
CREATED BY THEE THE
AN
A.BLW CLIMATE AND  INNIO
HELPING BRIN COMMUNITY INTO
st CEN. PERSONAL LOVE
FRIEND TO TRAVELEAMILES BAE AKHI
THUSIASTRO
GRADTERD GO RING
SOOWTH, WITHTURE, YO
DON'LET ANYBODY TEOU
AND NT THIS MOMENT
CHASL HEGIVES.
WHEN I FIR TOO AMAYOR, IN TYOFC
IN CORE.TYUNLOCKING NEW ECONOMIC
WELTP PARTNEHI T
PRVICE TO
PUBLIC/PT
PU
OF BICILITY.
SUPPORT FOR WERK YOUORMS
CHE.E FOR A MORE
CHALLENGES CREATED WOULD
FEDERAL AND STATE INFRASTRUCTUR
OERY LANE MILE AND F OUCITY, O
MAYORS, THE POTH
A COMMUNITY WHERE MOHATEIDENTS
IN POVERTY, WE WL INTHE GAPS THE
UNDERFUNDED TRANSIS OO
OPPORTUNITY JUSTE THE MEANS
MAKETHERICAN DREAM
POGETTINPEDIRECTLY AND INDIRECTG
OD
AT ITS, MISGUIDED POLICIESAND MM
VIG HB
UNDERMINING GONT'S BEM TVE.STORS
CREATEOBS,LE EQUITABLY SERVE
AL
NGO ENSURE E SAFETY OF TRAVELER
WO
AMERICA HAS GIVETH
ADMIST A MANTO
AND STEP ONE IS TO BUILDS SHOUL
R PEERS INVET COS TO
OUR ROADIDD TRANSISYSTEM SOME .
FROM EVERY LABOR SINESS, LEFT,R
HAS AICAN INFRASTRUCTURE TO
BETTER .S EXPECT U SEEHE IDE A
INFRASTRRECIH RESULTS AND
A PUNCH LINE.
MY VIEOF THIPORTUNITY IS
ALSO SHAPEHEYOUNO
THIS CABINETFIT  ITO THAT TABLEA
STAKE IN INFRASTRUPOY ITS NATUR
ANE LONG TERMG
HO
LOOK BY THE MILEF THIS
CPEHEURITY  M INOICS .
AND I'M ALSO THATHESE ON THI
APPOINTMENG THAT THI
OPELGBTQ CABINET MEMBOR TION.ES
NA
A STOI OIN BE
AMBASSORNIE IN
ULTIMATELYE TO SERVEY BY APPOIN
IDENT TO ANYTHING.ATE I S HOPIN
THOSE LITSE ALWO DECADEST WATCHS
WHMIUT THINK OF 17-YEAR-OLD
US RIGHT NOWETHER ANE THEYE WOR
ANBOE THATODING TO T
SO THANKT, THANK YOU FOR  YOUR
YOU HAD DA        U
ENCOURAGEMENT AND FRIENDIPTHERE.
EVERY TIME UP
ERYONE TIEMCAME TO WORINTEIS
H
PANDEMIC AIVERIN
TO ALL WHO NEED IT.
WE AOUR SCOLD SIBLY OUR
, WE
ARE ALSO FOCUSEDILDINGR. I UP AE
BS, RURAL AREAS,
IN BEE OF MOST WAYSLL DUNIO T
MAINTAIN A SAFE MO
SUSTAINATRANSPORTATIONEM.
BRIDGES, T SYSTEMS, S ITY.
RAWA ERG
SPK  AMERICAN
PASSENGER RAILT  LY COND
ACROSS O MANUFACTURING SECTOR.
WAY THAT  SIZE,
AN ACROSS Y.NT-ELECTDE T SPEARHD
WORK ITO KNOPER THE LA
COUPLE OF YEARS, WE TRAVELED TO
THTEATE
WED LONG CE RE OABE NEED FOR
BIPARTISANSHIP AND ABO FAMILY
AND FAE  PET
WONDERFUN HAVE
INS AN STRAIGHT  FRIENDS O
DIFFERENCE PROBLEM SOLVER. INTE
PEOPLE.S A TRAIZIEA